he's the much-loved Monarch who sets the
chaotic events of House of the Dragon in
motion but why was the so-called good
King so popular here's a quick lesson on
the show Game of Thrones ended its epic
run back in May of 2019 and now House of
the Dragon is bringing fans back to
Westeros in droves though this time
they're watching a story sit nearly two
centuries before the original series
focusing on the powerful Dragon riding
Targaryen family long before their
descendant Daenerys ever traveled on
Dragon back House of the Dragon kicks
off even earlier than that with a
council that chooses viserys Targaryen
as the new monarch when there's not a
clear line of succession chosen over his
cousin princess rhaenice as the next
King of the Seven Kingdoms viserys is on
the surface Affair just king with a good
heart who's always trying to do what's
best for the realm as king it is my
obligation to avoid war until such time
it is unavoidable with that said it
seems like those around him don't take
him particularly seriously and everyone
from raynese to her husband Corliss
Valerian to the now former hand of the
king Otto Hightower frequently outsmart
and manipulate the king for their own
purposes so who chooses viserys as the
next ruler of the realm well that would
be the great Council of King jaharis
Targaryen briefly played by Michael
Carter in the series premiere of House
of the Dragon why does jaharis Loom so
large over viserys and what exactly was
his legacy known by the nickname good
King jaharis the first was one of the
most popular kings in the history of the
Seven Kingdoms though his fellow beloved
King aegon the Conqueror was known as a
fierce Warrior and was the first King of
the Seven Kingdoms Jairus held an
important record as the longest reigning
monarch in the history of the realm
according to George R.R Martin's Source
material Fire and Blood jahiris ruled
the Seven Kingdoms for a whopping 55
years and by all accounts they were
pretty uniformly good ones as well
jairus's Legacy is also pretty storied
he's credited with keeping the realm
peaceful and prosperous and he also was
able to forge truces between warring
houses to keep things level including
one between house Bracken and House
Black Blackwood two houses of the
riverlands and his youth jaharis was
also a formidable fighter facing off
personally against dornish forces during
a skirmish known as the third dornish
war and in the early days of his Reign
he more or less created a system of laws
that would govern the realm for
centuries to come finally he was also
famous as a dragon rider he rode Verma
Thor who was the third largest dragon in
westerosi history behind balerion whose
skull resides in the crypts of King's
Landing and vegar whose whereabouts are
unknown during the events of House of
the Dragon so far faced with a lack of
direct heirs joharis and his great
Council eventually chooses his grandson
viserys over his granddaughter reynis
but did he make the right choice as the
series opens viserys is awaiting the
birth of his second child whom he hopes
will be a son though it is the infant
dies along with viserys's first wife
Emma leaving him heartbroken though he
then names his daughter and only child
reynera as His official Heir he goes on
to marry again and produces a son aegon
whose mere existence kicks off the
central conflict of House of the Dragon
viserys is for the first five episodes
in miserably poor health and seemingly
ineffective he's unable to shut down the
armies if the stepstones leaving his
brother Damon and Corliss to clean up
his mess add it to the chair
at the end of we light the way the fifth
episode the king flat out collapses and
who knows what his health will be like
moving forward episode 6 promises a
massive time Jump and whatever happens
next it's all thanks to the good King